it is transgender awareness week and
while the group that makes up the t in
lgbtq has made strides the transgender
population still faces unique challenges
and obstacles especially in the
workplace a new mckinsey report finds
that the group is underrepresented
underemployed and underpaid so here to
tell us more is jill zucker a senior
partner at mckenzie jill welcome to
quick take thank you so much for joining
us today
thanks for having me so i want to start
by making sure that we're all on the
same page when it comes to language
because this is
confusing for a lot of people and the
first page of your report actually
tackles this with a glossary so what
does the term
transgender include
so
part of this is exactly as you say
scarlet about language and transgender
as we define it in this report are
people who don't identify with the sex
they were assigned at birth
what about cisgender then so cisgender
is those who identify with the sex that
they were assigned at birth and so we
compare and contrast those two
through our report and we
did a survey of populations 250 people
from both populations to try to get to
some of the insights that we have today
okay so thank you for making that clear
first off so let's dig into the state of
transgender people in the workplace
because what you found is that they are
less likely to be employed and when they
are working they're making less money as
well
that's correct and so transgender
people are two times more likely to be
unemployed and even when they are
employed they make up to 40 percent less
money even when you normalize for
college education and so this really is
a state of how do we create more equity
and inclusion for this population but as
you said
it's not on the radar screen of most hr
departments today in part because we
don't have a language and we don't have
a shared vocabulary to even talk about
it or comfort with the vocabulary uh so
that we can help these people
why is it that they make less money is
is there are there a number of reasons
for that
so the top line here is that 50 of
transgender people don't feel
comfortable bringing their whole selves
to work and we all know as we've looked
at all sorts of affinity groups if you
can't bring your whole self to work you
can't perform at your best
why can't they bring their whole selves
to work well 60 of them just fear for
their safety
and so if you're worried about your
safety in the workplace then you
certainly can't perform at your best
okay let's let's dig into that a little
bit more because that's one of our big
numbers nearly 60 percent of survey
respondents cited physical safety as one
of their biggest concerns especially in
figuring out where they want to work
explain that a little bit more what
sense of safety is it their personal
safety just getting around and talking
to people and sharing who they really
are or um
are they working outdoors are they
working with different kinds of people
are they customer facing i just need
some more detail here
yeah well it's both physical and mental
safety uh 2020 we saw nearly 45 deaths
in this community people who were killed
because they were transgender so hate
crimes if you will 2021's on track to be
even worse for this population so
there's a true physical safety aspect of
it but then there's also mental
health and people here are confused
about their identity in some instances
or they're not confused but they're
confused about how they portray
themselves in the workplace and we
really need to support this community so
they can
strive and and be successful in the
workplace and what you found is that at
least when it comes to the workplace
this community tends to cluster in
certain industries and perhaps avoid
others what did you learn
so we learned that this community tends
to cluster in food and retail
there's a safety and numbers there but
unfortunately they tend to be in
somewhat lower paying and lower growth
jobs in those industries and so that
contributes to the wage gap if we could
close that wage gap it's both good for
this community but it's good good for
the economy
overall we we think that closing that
wage gap can contribute up to 12
trillion in consumer spending
which would benefit all of us i mean
it's a bit of a footnote let's focus on
safety first but then
there is a greater good here yeah well
there are certain executives who are
only moved by the numbers and that 12
trillion dollar number will certainly
get their attention mckinsey is a
management consultant giant you guys
streamline and optimize processes for
companies so when you produce this kind
of research and these findings and you
show it to clients
how do they turn these findings into
action what do you suggest to them
so i think part of this is setting the
foundation
this is not a topic that's been on the
radar screen of most most hr departments
we talk about the community of lgbtq
plus as an aggregate community this is
one of the first times we said actually
different parts of that community need
different support and so that was just
eye-opening in some of our client
conversations and then we talk about
what do you need to do to support the
transgender community in your workplace
well let's start with not having gender
as a field in the application process
let's ask people to have both their
preferred names as opposed to their
legal names we we hear from transgender
uh colleagues in the workplace and say
they get outed at work because they get
their legal name is what gets you gets
used that's what's in the hr system
that's not what they prefer to be using
and that's not how they want to be
identified by and then they deal with
microaggressions of people saying oh
you're so believable i would never have
known well that's their choice whether
or not to communicate that they
shouldn't be outed by an hr system if
you will yeah so these solutions sound
really reasonable and sound like they
don't necessarily need to be a heavy
lift do corporate executives and hr
departments see it that way as well that
this is something they can implement
really quickly
i think so i think there is a desire to
be more inclusive in the workplace
generally we've seen that across
populations i think the goal of this
report was to create awareness and the
language to do so i think the next step
here is how do we create trans-friendly
benefits people don't feel comfortable
asking the question of an hr department
but we talk about family-friendly
benefits we talk about egg freezing and
fertility and we're out in front of some
of those things in the recruiting and
the hiring process let's also talk about
uh trans-friendly benefits and not make
people ask about it but have those
things available at the outset so people
feel like it's a workplace that will be
inclusive and understanding what are
some examples of trans friendly benefits
well it's both the mental health but
also the physical health people are
going through hormone replacement
therapies and changes and so making sure
that those things are part of the
benefit packages
is an important piece of the puzzle here
i know mckinsey publishes an annual
women in the workplace report and and
you mentioned that this finding this
report on the transgender community is a
first uh this is something that you
hadn't really delved into before so i'm
just curious as to what catalyzed this
closer examination was there anything in
the women in the workplace study that
prompted you to take a closer look at
the transgender population
yeah well women in the workplace as you
likely know surveys over 300 companies
uh across the corporate america in the
u.s and we started to look at the
respondents and there we ask people to
identify their gender and we give a very
expansive definition of gender for
people to select and we started to see
some of these nuggets around safety and
inclusion and the ability to bring your
whole self to work around the
microaggressions that i shared and
we weren't sure if there was something
there or not we went to our own trans
community at mckinsey and started to ask
folks is there something here and that
prompted us to to dive deeper so in
fairness we didn't set out to write it
but as we saw the
insights we said let's dig a little bit
deeper and and we got to this report and
we're really proud that we put it out
we're also proud of the response that
we're getting uh in terms of people
responding on social media and alike
yeah tell me a little bit more about
that because it's not often that you get
so many personal responses
to the reports that you put out
what are people saying to you
people are very appreciative i mean
we've just put the report out as you
know in trans awareness week we've had
over 15 000 uh looks on on linkedin and
elsewhere i've personally received a
number of messages from trans people in
the workplace thanking us for doing the
report asking to connect one-on-one
about their experiences and so
you know it's
i publish reports often i i don't
usually get this type of one personal
outreach or
uh certainly this level of
uh views on these topics so this is
really a first and something that we're
proud of in that sense you definitely
hit a chord there joe thank you so much
for sharing the results of this report
for uh with us jill zucker is a senior
partner at mckinsey and co of course
talking about the transgender uh
community in the
firm's transgender week
examination